こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
みなさん、「うまい棒」って知っていますか。
この国民的お菓子、うまい棒でございます。
今日はですね、Ｔｗｉｔｔｅｒのリプでこんなものを頂きました。
「うまい棒は油でできているので、 燃やすと爆発するらしいです。ぜひやってみてください。」
分かりました。ぜひやりましょう。
用意する物はこちら
以上でございます。
では、さっそくやっていきましょう。
今日は前振りが短くて良いって？
ありがとう
うまい棒を今回、3種類用意させて頂きました。
コーンポタージュ味と、
チーズ味と、
たこやき味でございます。
あああっ～！
やってるように見えるんですけれど、
ＣＧグラフィックの合成で火は出ているので
実際は爆発するんで、やめとけよ！
本当に爆発するのか、さっそくやっていこうと思います。
まずは、うまい棒チーズ味からです。
粉！ 誰のイタズラだ。
危ないとは言いつつね、
火炎放射を使って作る調理方法とかもあるんで、
まあ一種の調理ですね。
こんな感じです
でもね、あんまり信じてないんだよね。
じゃあいきます
あー、怖っ！やばっ
まあ調理だよ、調理
爆発すんの？
３，２，１，
ファイヤー
みんな！伏せろ！！
（噴射音）
熱っ！！
あ、めっちゃ うめえ
え… おいしい。
絶妙に焦げ目とかもついて…なんか、めっちゃ香ばしい
これ普通のうまい棒よりおいしいぞ
これうめえわ！
次  コーンポタージュ味です
まじ うまい
普通のうまい棒よりおいしい
最後、たこやき味です
めっちゃ香ばしくなるんだよね。
これやばいわ。すっごいおいしい。
できたてのうまい棒っていう味がします。
♪～
これはおいしいわ。
という訳で ぜひみんなもね、
うまい棒はちょっと燃やしたら香ばしいというか、
10円の安いお菓子の味じゃなくなります。
うま味の効いた味っていうか、
ちょっとだけ火あぶりにして食うと、とてもおいしいです。
みなさんぜひ 試してみましょう。
じゃあな！
爆発しねえじゃねえか
（エンディング曲）